this is the plane wreckage from the  douglas dc-3 missing for 54 years  a group of mountaineers had been hiking  in chile for four days when they  stumbled upon the site of  it was very overwhelming it made me feel  all sorts of things mixed emotions  you could feel the very potent energy of  the place you could breathe in the  sadness  among the 24 passengers were eight  professional soccer players from the  popular top division chilean team green  cross they were returning from an away  game  the plane took off in castro it  disappeared without a trace about 300  kilometers south of santiago  the pilot had previously reported ice on  parts of the aircraft  the exact site of the crash is being  kept secret  we know that places like this often  attract trophy hunters who want to come  and take things as souvenirs  revealing the site would put it at risk  of being looted  investigators can now use the wreckage  to establish what happened all those  years ago